alright however you received the
president's address tonight one thing
should not be missed the president
scored a major media coup what am I
talking about
he got all the major networks to carry
his address galvanizing the attention of
the entire country and he accomplished
something else he got two of the least
popular politicians in the nation to
respond to him on his terms he wants to
raise the stakes and make the Democrats
the co-owners of this shutdown and I
think Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer are
walking right into the trap he brings
everyone in and this is the Trump trap
he negotiates through brinksmanship and
that's just not a way to get to a
rational ending
okay but this is rational the president
is rejecting these bipartisan bills
which would reopen government over his
obsession with fortune forcing American
taxpayers to waste billions of dollars
on an expensive and ineffective wall we
don't govern by temper tantrum president
Trump has appealed to fear not facts
division not unity there's an obvious
solution separate the shutdown from
arguments over border security okay now
the contract should be glaring for
anyone who watched tonight the president
was really sober and his address is
extremely serious and he genuinely
believes that a wall is needed as part
of a larger border Security's policy so
he campaigned on that's what he won on
Democrats do not give a damn about
securing the border for them this is all
about scoring political points and of
course about 2020 we have always been
willing to talk to the president about
border security and many of us have
supported some pretty massive
investments in border security in the
past but we can't do that well the
government is shut down we need to open
up government and then negotiate not the
other way around we believe in secure
borders but we want the government open
once the government is open I would
support looking at a broader compromise
on immigration all right don't believe
anything they're telling you there
for just not even a millisecond the
Democrats are targeting in the 800,000
government workers on furlough they're
targeting them what do I mean they
refused to move even a millimeter the
Democrats toward a common-sense
compromise of the president now remember
a year ago they were willing to give him
twenty five billion dollars for a wall
schumer ultimately pulled that off the
table but they were willing to do that
now today they can't even come up with a
measly five billion dollars think of all
the waste fraud and abuse in this town
that they could trim away to get that
five billion dollars we'll talk about
that in a bit the president has shown a
willingness to compromise you heard it
tonight in a funding request to the
Senate Appropriations Committee this
week the president asked for items that
are also important to Democrats he
alluded to this tonight
of course 800 million dollars for
humanitarian needs at the border and
that includes medical support and
additional facilities to house migrants
which frankly a lot of Americans
probably think would be better spent on
inner-city youth in our veterans but
nevertheless the president's willing to
go there the president's also requesting
675 million dollars for new technology
to detect and stop the flow of illegal
drugs over the border
Democrats have long said they wanted
that but Democrats don't want to have an
honest conversation about border
security they are now the party of
obstruction and everything must bend to
they're resist Trump goals the hill
reports that their latest strategy is to
jam up the Senate by refusing to
consider any legislation until the
government is reopened this could not be
business as usual if we shut down a
quarter of the government and just leave
it shutting down it's a it's an
incompetent strategy now just to give
you a sense of how dogmatic how rabbit
and how fanatical this resistance to
trump has become look no further than
the Democrats who voted against
considering a bill to support Israel
earlier today what so we're not going to
support
boy oppose boycotts against Israel
because Trump is wants to do a deal on
the border wall how is that governing in
a mature way now I'm sure the new
anti-semitic wing of the Democratic
Party was thrilled about this
development in the Senate but
nevertheless most Americans aren't again
don't focus on what they say it sounds
fine kind of reasonable watch what they
do the Democrats want this shutdown to
go on as long as possible to divide as
many Republicans from the president as
they can they want to peel one off after
another and then they want to ratchet up
the political pressure our safety and
our security forget that bellow that's
damned
if they wanted the government reopen the
Democrats could negotiate with the
President and reopen the government
tomorrow
he's already compromised on the
structure of the wall and he's dropped
his asking price as we now weigh down
and while the Democrats feign concern
over spending a few billion on the
border wall 5.7 billion the coastal
wonder twins of their party governor
Newsom of California and Mayor DeBlasio
of New York have all kinds of money we
find pots of money for the health care
of illegal immigrants we will never
waver in our pursuit of guaranteed
health care for all Californians
healthcare is a human right in this city
we're gonna make that a reality in this
city we're taking that ideal and putting
it into practice from this moment on in
New York City everyone is guaranteed the
right to health care well they have no
problem finding all that money falling
from the sky to spend on the well-being
and health of illegal aliens my friends
like everything else this is all about
politics for the Democrats pretty much
every demographic group in the country
right now is better off than they were
just a few years ago think about that
but the Democrats didn't have any answer
to that it's not like they're gonna go
out there and argue okay we're gonna
offer these three policies and they're
gonna raise your standard of living to a
higher level than President Trump has
been able to do they've given up on that
all they have to run on is this shutdown
and their opposition to the wall oh
sorry
and Trump's a racist that's all they
have oh and for an added bonus they
actually believe that this stalemate
with the shutdown furnishes them with
another political weapon to guess what
further the real Nirvana for Americans
because this is really gonna help your
life get better the impeachment agenda
yes Trump's threat to end the shutdown
by declaring a national emergency which
never happened in building the wall
himself could hasten the Democrats
ultimate desired end this kind of abuse
of power may also open up other measures
for Congress because this in fact could
hit the tripwire of abuse of power which
is also one of those things that could
lead to a presidential impeachment this
morning I was like wow you're really
spitting it out
well the Democrats are straining to
squeeze the last bit of political juice
from this shutdown the president's doing
the right thing he's focused on the
security and the sovereignty of the
American people and their prosperity
it's a posture that's good policy but in
time it's also going to prove to be good
politics as well mark my words
and that's the angle